Welcome to the Man of Recaps.
This is Ahsoka, season one.
Ahsoka Tano was introduced
in The Clone Wars animated series,
she was Anakin Skywalker's apprentice.
She came to live action
in The Mandalorian season two,
where she and Mando teamed up
to take down the evil Morgan Elsbeth.
Now in Ahsoka’s own series,
she tracks down the plot thing
evil lady was looking for.
She fears it's a map to the lost
Imperial leader, Grand Admiral Thrawn.
He's a military genius
that was a main villain
in Star Wars Rebels,
and of course, the old novels before that.
You can watch my recap
to get the full Rebels story,
but at the end Thrawn was defeated
by our hero, the Young Jedi Ezra Bridger.
He got help from the Space Whales,
the Purrgil who grabbed Thrawn’s ship
and warped them both out of there!
And Thrawn is a serious threat,
his return would unite
all the ex-imperial forces
and kick off another war.
So now on the Rebels main planet, Lothal,
we realize this show is Rebels
Ahsoka
gets the gang back together, recruits
ace pilot Hera Syndulla,
now a General in the New Republic,
and still hanging out with the team's
droid Chopper, the chaotic mayhem machine.
But the main focus in the show is our
rebellious Mandalorian artist Sabine Wren.
Apparently
Ahsoka tried to take her as an apprentice,
but these two ended up butting heads.
But now Ahsoka's got the plot thing that
can help her find her lost friend, Ezra.
But Morgan Elsbeth has just broken out
of prison with help from a new Dark Jedi,
Baylan Skol.
He has an apprentice, Evil Bangs
Girl, and sends her after Sabine
for an apprentice fight.
Sabine's out of practice
and she gets stabbed!
But don't worry, she's fine,
who needs a spleen, anyway?
So now Sabine is ready to get serious,
ritualistically cuts her hair.
Alright Ahsoka, let's do this.
She starts training with Ahsoka’s
droid Huyang,
who was an old Jedi training droid.
And Sabine is a top tier fighter,
but she doesn't have much connection to the Force.
Asoka explains
she's a little force sensitive,
but way less than all the Jedi we know.
Meanwhile,
the bad guys open up their space map,
which answers how Ezra and Thrawn
have been missing this whole time,
I mean, the Star Wars
galaxy isn’t that big... relatively.
But turns out
they're in a different galaxy,
which for space, is really far away.
So Sabine
and Evil Bangs have their rematch,
while Ahsoka goes for Baylan Skoll.
“Hey we never met, who are you,
what’s your deal?”
Well,
turns out he seems like a cool guy
who wants to do the greater good.
But his greater good is clearly bad,
so he and Ahsoka have a lightsaber fight!
And Baylan Skoll is no scrub,
he's got Ahsoka on the ropes.
In fact, woah! Knocks her off the cliff!
Sabine got the map.
She's going to destroy it
so they can't find Thrawn.
But that would mean
she can't find Ezra either.
And so Sabine gives him the map back,
taking a pretty big gamble here.
So Baylan enters the coordinates, then
destroys the map so no one can follow them,
and it's time for the bad guys
intergalactic hyperspace jump!
Ahsoka meanwhile didn't die,
she wakes up in the World Between Worlds,
which we know from Rebels
is like a mystical Jedi place.
And here she's reunited with her old master,
yes Hayden Christensen back as Anakin Skywalker!
He tells her
he's got a new lesson for her,
and they go to a flashback to when
she was a kid fighting in the Clone Wars.
She realizes
Jedi shouldn't be fighting in the war,
Jedis whole thing,
they're supposed to be nonviolent.
At the time Anakin thought the only way
to stop violence is with more violence.
And now Ahsoka realizes
maybe that was wrong
and led him down
the path to the Dark Side.
So now Ahsoka and Dark Side Anakin
have themselves a lightsaber rematch!
But Ahsoka doesn't kill him,
throws the lightsaber away.
“Yes, a Jedi should choose nonviolence.”
Meanwhile Hera finally arrives,
she was caught up in New Republic
bureaucracy.
Most people are trying to do good,
but there's still a lot of secret
imperial loyalists.
Luckily, C-3P0 shows up to shut this guy
down.
Hera brought her son, Jacen Syndulla,
who like his father before him is Force sensitive,
and is able to figure out
where Ahsoka is in the water.
With the map destroyed
Ahsoka can't follow,
unless she asks directions
from the Purrgil themselves!
Yeah these space squid whales are maybe
super cute, or maybe Eldritch Horrors.
But Ahsoka’s not scared, parks
inside one’s mouth for some
space whale intergalactic hitchhiking.
Meanwhile,
the bad guys are in this new galaxy,
but turns out it's not a new galaxy,
it's an old galaxy.
It's the original home
world of the Night Sisters,
the witches of Dathomir,
of whom Morgan Elsbeth is a descendant.
And now pulling up
in an old Star Destroyer, oh yes it's
the man himself, Grand Admiral Thrawn!!!
He’s ready to come back
and restart the Empire,
he just needs a day to load up something
from the witch's temple.
So for now, he's
reunited with his old enemy Sabine Wren,
and it's like yeah go ahead,
go look for Ezra,
if she manages to find him,
you guys kill them both.
So Sabine befriends
some rock turtle aliens.
And who's living with them
but her friend Ezra Bridger!
All grown up now, he’s grown out a beard.
But the bad guys catch up to him,
and it's a big fight.
Meanwhile, Ahsoka finally arrives,
the space whales brought her to the right planet.
As Sabine has round three with her
rival, Evil Bangs,
Ahsoka goes for the rematch with Baylan.
But she runs away, and he doesn't pursue,
Baylan Skoll has his own mysterious goal.
So Ahsoka joins the fight and turns
the tide, it looks like our good guys win!
But Grand
Admiral Thrawn is a genius strategist.
This whole thing was part of his plan.
He distracted them with his least
favorite stormtroopers,
while the rest of them finished
loading the ship.
They’re ready to go back to their home galaxy,
leaving
the good guys stranded here.
But Thrawn’s not taking any chances, sends
some Tie Fighters
after them to disable their ship.
But the Jedi just ride in on wolves,
so Thrawn's backup plan
he sends more stormtroopers at them.
But two and a half Jedi can take down
an infinite number of stormtroopers.
But Thrawn had a backup backup plan,
he had the witches do a magic ritual...
Oh! Brings them back
as zombie stormtroopers!
This slows them down a bit, but they're
still on their way to stop that ship.
But Thrawn has a triple backup plan,
the witches give Morgan Elsbeth
their power, and their secret shadow
magic sword.
She delays Ahsoka while Ezra and Sabine
are ambushed
by super strong zombie troopers.
Sabine's in trouble, it's time for her
to figure out how to use the Force...
Oh! Grabs
her lightsaber, takes this thing out.
But the ship’ss getting away,
the only way to catch
it is with a double Force jump,
oh the jump and push!
Sabine's going to do the jump and pull,
but now Ahsoka’s in trouble.
So just as it looks like Ahsoka's
defeated, Sabine jumps in!
Yes she stayed behind to fight with her
new mentor Ahsoka.
Huyang managed to fix their ship,
so they've got a chance
they could still catch Thrawn.
But Thrawn still has one backup plan left...
He opens a channel just to say “Hey.”
Because he won, they can't catch him,
and he light speeds out of there
back to our galaxy,
leaving Sabine and Ahsoka stranded.
But they're not giving up, there's still
a lot of mysteries about this planet.
Evil Bangs is still out there,
she rounds up the local barbarians
like “Hey
what's up, I guess I’m your leader now?”
And Baylan Skoll is dramatically
standing up on old statues.
He seems to know something about
the ancient mystical lore of this place,
what is his plan?
And watching over his apprentice
Ahsoka is Force Ghost Anakin Skywalker!
Yeah he made it to Ghostville!
Back in the main galaxy, a lone
stormtrooper boards the Republic ship.
Yes indeed, it's Ezra Bridger who escaped.
Good news, I'm back, bad news,
Ahsoka and Sabine were left behind,
and Thrawn is back too.
He's setting up at the witch's planet
Dathomir.
He's got some secret plan
that involves all the stuff he took from
that witch temple.
What's in these boxes?
You know it's not good.
Grand Admiral Thrawn is back
and ready to revive the Empire.
And that’s
where Ahsoka season one comes to an end.
If you like this recap,
hit that subscribe button for more of the
best recaps of TV and movies.